I'm just gonna bring in Ronnie the robot  for the news Ronnie the robot was  developed by our team if you can  artificially intelligent moronic the  robot stands about the same height as  Ronnie  five foot one Ronnie the robots creeping  me out  look at that thing staring what oh hello  I was Siri to be proud of my hole with a  strap-on something's telling me that  Ronnie the robot can't read some of  these things he's read and they make him  sense again is there a silent mode for  that thing no no no start again I think  he has an illiteracy virus what did you  say ladies and gentlemen I hate to admit  this but Ronnie the robot has been  hacked by the Russians we created the  world's dumbest robot